let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 first is our caller from the 905 area
code caller from 905 go right ahead
hello David can you hear me we can hear
you fine David my name is Paul and I'm
from Ontario and I probably have a few
questions here but let's start with one
let's go with the top one today
okay I'm offended by the phrase leader
of the free world I mean I'm assuming
that we're in all in democracy in this
free world right that they somebody
started this phrase from but I don't
consider mr. Trump or any President of
the United States the leader of the free
world I didn't vote for him I could
never vote for me I don't have a chance
to vote for him sure and if he's a
leader like how do you how do they get
it like where did that come from
yeah so this it's not as you as you
understand it's not a literal term
leader of the free world is a colloquial
term that historically refers to the
sort of Western leader that is deferred
to by other Western Allies and
historically it's been the President of
the United States that doesn't mean
everybody agrees right like you might
you're like to see laughs you might
disagree no matter who it is the sort of
I hate to say consensus but increasingly
the idea is that since Donald Trump has
been elected president and particularly
with the sort of destruction of the
alliances with Canada and France and
Germany and other countries increasingly
German Chancellor Angela Merkel is being
considered again it's colloquial the
leader of the free world so it's not a
literal term it's nothing to be offended
about but it's this colloquial idea I'm
sort of pulling your leg no okay well I
hope it was worth it because I do have
12 people holding and I got to move on
but I appreciate I appreciate the phone
call may have been a waste of a phone
call there i if it was all a joke than I
apologize